enfin pour les mineurs délinquants plus
de place dans les prisons mais aussi la
création de centres éducatifs fermés il
est question d'en construire un par
département doté de 40 places alors la
création de ces structures fermées elle
ne serait pas une première en france
on se souvient par exemple des maisons
de correction le dernier établissement
de ce genre a fermé ses portes il ya 25
ans pourquoi et dans quelles conditions
celles en quête de cette édition elle
est signé agnès garder jean francois
monier mais très petites communes
d'indre et loire a jamais connu pour son
bann yeux d'enfants
l'ouverture officielle en mon talent
années 1840 de toute la france les
enfants quittent leur prison pour cet
établissement qui ne dit pas encore son
nom régime extrêmement sévère travaux
forcés conditions de vie précaires
mais bon on en mettrait une cellule
m'ont fait déshabiller nu la cellule
étaient environ peut-être nous arrangent
leurs aînés jusqu'à 16 heures je suis
resté là attendre tout nu la cellule se
défera 23 ans et s'il fait froid
par mesure d'économie on avait pris un
personnel de fortune de sorte qu'on
trouvait à mes traits comme surveillant
c'est à dire comme éducateur d'un mois
un ancien forçat un tueur des abattoirs
au bout du jardin le cimetière où
reposent les corps de deux cents enfants
morts d'épidémie selon les uns mort
suspecte pour d'autres des soupçons qui
viendront alimenter une campagne anti
bagne dans les années 30
ces établissements disparaîtront
progressivement l'ordonance du 2 février
45 sur l'enfance délinquante craie le
métier d'éducateur au nom d'un principe
la primauté de l'éducatif sur le
répressif
c'est le temps de l'éducation surveillée
et de ses maisons de correction où
s'entassent des jeunes gens par dizaines
l'idée des centres fermés a germé au
milieu des années 60 il fallait alors
créer 1500 places de sécurité
alternative à la prison
d'où les délinquants ne pourrait
s'enfuir à l'abandon aujourd'hui ce
complexe de petits pavillons l'unique
expérience en france de centre fermé les
portes étaient fermées à clé de nuit il
y avait possibilité d'interrompre
l'électricité à l'intérieur par des
dijon corps individuel et la fenêtre qui
éclaire cette petite chambre cellule
monacale est une fenêtre qui ne
pouvaient pas sourire et fait d'un verre
à l'épreuve des balles
un mur d'enceinte de six mètres de haut
un monde clos spécialement conçu pour
empêcher les évasions pour son ancien
directeur une cocotte minute prête à
exploser à tout moment
les jaunes avaient transformé de temps
en temps l'établissement en un lieu où
il y avait des affrontements très
difficile à supporter et qui laissait
traumatisé le personnel et la plupart
d'entre eux il ne faut pas que la
sécurité prenne le pas sur l'éducation
sinon on est dans une prison qui ne veut
pas dire son nom était observé par on
est obsédé par le nombre par les popes
par les clés par où il est qu'est-ce qui
fait pourquoi il n'est pas là et quand
on est mobilisé comme ça on est moins
mobilisés sur l'éducation la famille
l'extérieur une vie en autarcie émaillée
de bagarres et de révolte conduisons peu
à peu à l'échec de l'expérience
il y sera mis fin en 79 après les
résultats d'une étude 100% de récidive
laisser 200 pensionnaires ont tous
après leur passage ici connu la prison